all right so is Goliath time we're gonna
start off by gaining some distance and
then Shaolin down mm-hmm because those
hunters are coming in you get a little
bit of a head start the hunters right
now are like flying down I think it
gives you what not a lot maybe 15
seconds of a head start to kind of get
going you can push in your you're right
stick to smell pretty effective that
leap smash was pretty terrible but I do
see some Kilda's things down here do
this real quick three meet you can see
it on the meter right there monkeys are
typically to meet and then there's like
a few I don't know what they look like
pro Compsognathus as they're like tiny
little bird walking birds dodo birds
they're only worth one so those monkey
should only be worth two so this thing
starts giving me crap in on the giant
monster like I so did and so while I'm
eating all of these things I can sniff
see if any of the hunters are coming
near me but doesn't look like it yet
they are not yet so my hope my shields
were a little down all right where's my
last meets
sniffing it out you'll also notice I
think you're towards the edge of the map
which is a little bit dangerous because
it gives you less place to run if he
gets into a tricky spot so watch them
birds here numbered that's true all
right no all right you'll notice
there'll be birds on the map they
obviously all you're getting it was
gnarly yeah they'll hurt you so I do not
want to deal with those things it's not
worth it yeah I'm ready to evolve so I'm
just gonna go up on topic here actually
just going to go right behind here and
do this do it so to evolve you make a
really gross noise to like all right so
I'm already level two good job I'm gonna
pick up the rock throw cuz i'm gonna try
to engage as i go for double beef smash
and i'm gonna pick up the charge just to
have that now i gotta wait boom I'm back
sniff you will notice ones around here
it is not a good idea to engage the
second you evolve why because he just
used all of his shield power to evolve
look at his shield now it's at the
minimum now that he's eaten some three
needs he's going to kind of recap that
shield once his shield is at max he's
ready to engage yeah I got hit by a
tranquilizer dart all that comes are all
right back you're there I'm gonna go
you're gonna jet yeah I'm gonna get out
of this shield is really low I think a
good hunt what separates a good monster
from a great monster is knowing when is
the time to take to take down the
hunters chris knows he could absolutely
engage and do some damage he'll do more
damage if he's fully shielded up so i'm
gonna get this guy cuz its release try
to get perk by eating this thing i'm
fifty percent faster actually going to
linger around here thanks is free me
just some free meets all of those
hunters hunters left some free meets
laying around certainly good again more
than happy to take advance yum yum yum
that's a good reason again over there
why when you're a hunter
to not kill these to not kill for no
reason he's just eating right now you've
just made him more powerful in fact
you're probably ready to evolve not
quite but I am ready oh yeah all right
oh you do don't tranqs you want to
engage yeah let's do this let's engage
ok guys so alone are you your hater and
then the medic yeah medics not be by
themselves but they are he do not have
any backup no good did I hit it leaps
not forget it this is a huge mistake
automatic to be by themselves and now
they're dead they're down not only is he
going to keep it down he's going to kill
the Medicus and possibly consume its
body oh hello friend good job and knock
this guy off a cliff good job the other
dude Daisy is gonna try to revive the
medic definitely makes to not lose all
that work that you put into taking down
someone stick by their bodies a little
bit if someone tries to revive them
start killing them I'll of course
there's no reviving now he's officially
supe dead nice
I'm not getting damaged right here but
aren't getting heavy damage try to burn
this guy down the job my shields are
coming pretty low Oh your shields garage
nice good job that dude is down I'm
gonna go around and try to take out
delivered over here Oh
no you will not busy for days no
reviving there will be no reviving we'd
be dead oh no they're trying to revive
splash attack what's something cool to
see about Goliath powers is that he's
really meant to separate the group you
all so many of his moves push you and
the idea is get them away from each
other and kill them individually it's
hard to kill people when they have four
people around it's a lot easier to kill
you when you're by your lonesome that's
true so this engagement just one really
poorly for the guys I'm pretty sure
they're I think this is a very interests
so that was it that was the speed out
evolve real quick then get a bit of your
shields back and then I mean I think
their fatal flaw was having Val separate
from the last the medic was down there
was no chance of them to get any kind of
healing they did significant damage they
got all my shields down and they were
starting to chip away at the health but
then once you know once they start
falling it's like a domino effect and at
that point like it reaches a point where
if you're one of hunter's remaining you
just gotta flee because even if you're a
hunter is killed they go they will come
in on a drop [ __ ] it's like a dropship
it's like a two-minute 30-second timer
mm-hmm they will come in you probably
saw it in the upper left-hand corner of
the screen something that's really
important again to understand is to know
when to engage and know when to run away
you're such a monster ya gotta make your
monster face after winning not having
its but I was what I was playing that
cuz even though like I didn't really
feel threatened and flatly or I'm like
Chomp Chomp Chomp Chomp Chomp Chomp
Chomp Chomp of all right be ramen like
that's where Scott trends where they
said their vows not actually that far
away except they all stopped to get that
bonus and then I per state went that way
I pursued Val killed her then they'd owe
me but it was too late it was just like
dosey doe hang all around that rock so
when you're the monster like getting
around the rock and just trying to like
I was using my charge I was using my
leaf smash to scatter them and then
going around the sides of the rocks they
didn't have I wasn't in the open so
there
wasn't a lot of sight lines for them to
do damage to me while I was being
engaged alright the only thing better
than a three meat is a free meat